welding for unskilled workers this is a
chance to learn a trade and a stroke of
luck for Mohammed Faraj
I left Afghanistan 12 years ago now I'm
21 but I never learned to trade many
refugees from war-torn areas are in a
similar situation around 70 percent are
uneducated only around 30 percent have
other learned a trade or completed
studies a difficult challenge when it
comes to employment research has
estimate that every six refugee manages
to find a job as an unskilled worker in
their first year in Germany but not even
that is really sustainable feelings of a
problem medieval high demand smiles when
it smiles on the problems we have with
such migrants in urban centers is that
too little was done in the past to
prepare them for their current situation
in Connecticut perspectiva Givaudan huts
today migrants have better chances for
example this group is starting a course
in environmental technology they've
already completed a German language
course now they're learning how to
assemble electric motors the educational
backgrounds among the participants vary
sitting next to a former soldier from
Eritrea is a Syrian mechanical
engineering student luckily I have lots
of ideas of course I want to continue my
studies get my master's degree I'd like
to study Electrical Engineering if they
can do that they'll have much better
chances of finding work in Germany that
most monitors tonight them I first have
to fame and money to invest because
ultimately it will benefit society once
refugees are integrated into the labour
market
the taxes and social contributions they
pay will naturally rise better training
now means higher earnings later on and
so refugees will pay more in taxes and
social contributions in the beginning
most refugees are unemployed even those
with skills and education but once they
learn to speak German and continue their
training unemployment drops markedly
this is a furnace much like those used
in many German buildings repair
technicians are in great
and by heating companies refugees
studying at the Hamburg chamber of
trades and crafts are learning German
terminology then they'll learn to take a
part of furnace and put it back together
mechanical engineering students have an
advantage have you seen something like
this yeah they're different machines but
they all work the same whether pumping
oil or water they operate the same way
Germany has to integrate nearly half a
million refugees it's a daunting task
the estimated cost for the next 15 years
could reach 30 billion euros for food
housing and training the idea is to
invest more in education and training
because skilled workers can then find
jobs and take care of themselves just
lagging in for that's man what we say is
that 3 billion euros need to be invested
now that will enable the government to
save on Social Services so costs will
sink from 30 billion to less than 20
billion courses in environmental
technology are a good investment where
the refugees stay in Germany or someday
return to their homelands day uni-kit
Denton dodging refugees in Germany who
have learned how to build solar systems
or autonomous power stations could fill
positions for example critical to
serious reconstruction on a firm
confident V Delft ball the training will
last five months participants will also
become familiar with German companies
and perhaps find a position in a sector
desperate for trained staff